it's a hidden dragon Wow
[Music]
there were dragons when I was a boy
where they went only a few know our
story changed the world forever we did
it the world's first dragon Viking
utopia Julia don't be on maybe Mike's
lace Glenda did more oh Santa
honey hey wait up he's not the only one
she's a light fury you oh sorry
did he just disappear
Wow
it's a hidden dragon worth
[Music]
toothless go introduce yourself has a
girlfriend I've hunted every Night Fury
except yours and him over I will never
give him up then I will destroy
everything you love
we are no longer safe here we all have
to disappear completely off the map we
have to fight for their freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't nothing without your dragon
show them what you got
[Music]
save him
as you and me bud always
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie trailer week
continues we have new How to Train Your
Dragon if he didn't know they did make
another movie it's coming out next year
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you're finding me for the
first time but the big deal with this
like the new Dragon is called the light
fury because toothless is a Night Fury
so she's part of his subclass but
remember most night Furies were hunted
to extinction so the whole idea is is
that she represents the promise of
bringing those back but the way they're
describing her in the movie is that
she's wild untamed and you could see
that toothless has been domesticated
since the first movie they modeled
toothless after a cat so you could just
see like you know him being awkward
trying to introduce himself to the light
fury in their mating ritual like it's a
good analogy that animals that have been
domesticated lose the ability to survive
in the wild
and if toothless is going to help
repopulate his race of night Furies he
needs to go back into the wild with the
light fury so it's kind of like this sad
tale about how they're both growing up
and evolving they've been saying that
this movie is probably gonna be the last
one with these characters they're gonna
try and develop spin-off movies so
they'll be more like inside the world of
How to Train Your Dragon but the whole
idea is you see hiccup growing up
becoming more of a leader of his people
of humankind and toothless becoming more
of a leader of Dragon kind in order to
do that there's a certain natural order
to think so dragons were not meant to be
domesticated so you have this nice arc
across three movies with toothless and
hiccup like he's obviously gonna have to
ride off into the sunset with the light
fury at the end of the movie and maybe
hiccup becomes more of a leader of men
not just the people on this island like
he's the future leader of his own people
in the small community here but it
sounds like he keeps facing these
external challenges from these other
hunters so the only way to change that
in a really big way is to actually
become a bigger leader of people so that
he can influence things on a larger
scale like you can't control or stop
dragon hunting outright if you're trying
to deal with people from other nations
so the only way to do that is to become
a bigger leader of people across the
world but for the most part pretty much
all the big main actors are coming back
like
even kit harington's characters coming
back from the second one make all the
John snow Game of Thrones jokes that you
want no game you just wanna meet Drago
boy because I'm going to change his mind
about dragons I remember when the second
one came out because we'd already had
Daenerys dragons for a couple seasons at
that point but it was back in 2014 so we
were only on like season three of Game
of Thrones so like think about what was
going on in the show on that time so
there's a lot of analogies for Game of
Thrones going on in this to like
bringing dragons back into the world
going back to the natural order of
things just from a pure animation and
storytelling standpoint I feel like How
to Train Your Dragon is probably been
DreamWorks Animation's best franchise
you start with the first film it's all
about rediscovering dragons hiccup finds
toothless you learn the dragons aren't
evil they're not malevolent so they
start to coexist by the end of that
first film oh that a little Viking
island then by the second film it's like
a full-blown sanctuary you learn about
hiccups mother how she has been rescuing
dragons this whole time so it's sort of
like them bringing dragons back into the
world helping them flourish on their
little island then releasing them back
into the wild by the third film but if
you were confused about the timeline of
the trailer they give you most of the
story but they sort of cut in footage
from all three of the films so it's a
little confusing you have to look at
hiccup in his beard level so he's at
full beard by the third film like when
they find the dragon sanctuary that his
mother created that's during the second
film but the new villain of the third
film is played by F Murray Abraham if he
didn't recognize his voice
he's called grimille so he's basically
just another drago bludvist like he was
the villain of the second film the
person hunting down dragons so they're
not trying to pull any kind of Marvel
Avengers hope trailer situation where
they completely mislead you like he says
I'll take everything you love I'm
hunting down all night Furies the idea
being if he doesn't give toothless up
he'll kill the light fury and then
toothless doesn't have anybody to mate
with
so his subspecies will die off so they
need to rescue her so it's a pretty
clean arc in the film like rescue the
light fury helped toothless repopulate
his race but just let me know what you
think of the animation in the story so
far it just sounds like if this is all
about toothless mating with the light
fury then maybe hiccup is going to have
a baby at some point during the film
like he's going to have his
family too but I am kind of surprised
about how far along the animation is
when the film isn't coming out for
another nine months originally this was
scheduled to be released like way back
in 2017 but DreamWorks and DreamWorks
Animation went through all this
restructuring and a bunch of people got
fired so I think it just delayed the
project for a couple years so that's why
it's taken so long for this film to come
out but what's coming up is if you guys
didn't know III is gonna be happening
really soon I'll do trailer videos for
anything that's really relevant like
spider-man on the ps4 but leave all your
video requests in the comments below I
have some new flash that I'll post later
today where you wait for everything
click here for a new Avengers 4 teaser
and click here for that spider-man into
the spider virtual trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight